.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG WEEK.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
HERE WITH MORE IS THE AUTHOR OF
"HERE'S THE DEAL."
NUMBER ONE "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER, KELLYANNE CONWAY.
ALONG WITH THE POST OF THE LARRY
ELDER CHERYL, LARRY ELDER.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
KELLYANNE, LARRY'S STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
NOT BLAMING LARRY.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ELECTED.
THIS PROBLEM WILL BE SOLVED,
LET'S PUT IT THAT WAY.
THEY HAVE ALL THE NATURAL
RESOURCES.
THEY ARE CHASING PEOPLE OUT OF
THE STATE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
170 YEARS.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU COOL YOUR
HOME UP TO 4:00 P.M. AND THEN
PUT THE EASY UP TO 78.
OKAY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SWEATY IN
YOUR OWN BEDROOM AND YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO SLEEP.
PUBLIC ENEMY'S FAN.
HOW DOES THAT WORK WITH ELECTRIC
VEHICLES?
>> I'M COMING TO YOU FROM
CALIFORNIA.
THE PEOPLE HERE ARE ABUZZ ABOUT
THE MANDATES.
>> Sean: YOU ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
KELLYANNE MAY POP OUT OF THE
SCREEN.
IF THE LIGHTS GO OUT, WE KNOW
WHY.
>> WILL KNOW WHY.
LET'S STOP PICKING ON WORKING
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR THE HARVARD
EDUCATED DOCTORS LAWYERS AND
BUSINESS PEOPLE AND OTHER BEING
TOLD TO MAKE IT HOME FROM A
HARD DAY'S WORK AT 4:00 P.M.
THEY ARE READY TO OPEN THEIR
FRIDGE, COOK DINNER FOR THE
KIDS, FIRE UP THE
AIR-CONDITIONER.
THEY CAN'T TOUCH ANY OF THAT.
DON'T OPEN YOUR FRIDGE.
DON'T AIR-CONDITIONER HOUSE AND
DON'T COOK FOR YOUR FAMILY.
DON'T DO THE LAUNDRY.
IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE BUT
LISTEN I THINK NEWSOM 2024, HIS
PLATFORM IS STARTING TO TAKE
SHAPE.
OPEN BORDER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE STREETS OF SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE HE WAS MAYOR BEFORE HE WAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND GOVERNOR
LITTERED WITH NEEDLES AND FECES,
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS.
SHIPS AND CONTAINERS IN THE
PACIFIC WAITING TO UNLOAD.
IT'S BEYOND HYPOCRISY.
THE FACE OF THIS
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STARTS RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
KAMALA HARRIS, NANCY PELOSI,
GAVIN NEWSOM.
THOSE LIAR BIG MOUTHS SHIFT AND
SWALWELL.
IN ADDITION TO BEING HIPPER
CRITICAL AND HURTING AROUND
PEOPLE, GAVIN NEWSOM CAN'T GET .
HE TOOK THE KIDS OUT OF THE
SCHOOLS FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS.
HE MADE THEM SIT BEHIND A
COMPUTER AND EVERYBODY'S
KITCHENS.
PRETEND SCREEN TIME IS SCHOOL
TIME.
NOW YOU HAVE KIDS LEAVING
SCHOOLS EARLY OR CANCELING
CLASSES NOW IN PLACES LIKE
SAN DIEGO, DENVER, PHILLY, ALL
ACROSS IN DIFFERENT PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE AIR-CONDITIONING.
DO YOU KNOW CONGRESS PASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN COVID
RELIEF TO MAKE SURE THERE IS
PROPER VENTILATION, AIR
CONDITIONING.
THESE KIDS ARE OUT OF SCHOOL
AGAIN.
NOW YOU KNOW WHY GAVIN NEWSOM'S
IN-LAWS MOVED TO FLORIDA, VOTED
FOR RON DeSANTIS, GAVE MONEY
TO RON DeSANTIS ARE REGISTERED
REPUBLICANS.
IT STARTED IN THE NEWSOM
HOUSEHOLD.
>> Sean: THAT'S TRUE.
LARRY, IT'S YOUR ESTATE SO
PETE BUTTIGIEG HAS HEADED.
THEY HAVE SAID THEY WANT ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE WITH RENEWABLES
THEY WANT AMERICANS TO THINK
ABOUT BUYING A $20,000 EXTRA
COST ELECTRIC VEHICLE POWER BY
EXPLAIN TO ME WHY IT'S OKAY TO
IMPORT OIL FROM THE IRANIANS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DO THIS
DEAL.
OR THE VENEZUELANS ARE BIGGEST
AUDIS AND KISS THE ASS OF THE
CROWN PRINCE.
WHY IS IT OKAY TO GET ENERGY
FROM THEM ENOUGH PRODUCE IT
DOMESTICALLY?
NOBODY'S BEEN ABLE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION FOR ME.
>> I CONSIDER THAT TO BE A
RHETORICAL QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
IT'S NOT OKAY.
REMEMBER WHEN JEAN-PIERRE WAS
ASKED WHETHER OR NOT JOE BIDEN
EVEN OWNED IN EV, SHE DANCED
AROUND IT.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF WHO WANTS EVERYBODY TO GO
GREEN DOESN'T EVEN OWNED IN EV.
I'M IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S EVEN
WORSE.
SOME PEOPLE, NOT EVERYBODY, GOT
TEXTS FROM THE STATE URGING
PEOPLE NOT TO WATCH TELEVISION
DURING PEAK HOURS AT EITHER PLAY
CARDS OR TO WRITE A BOOK.
I KID YOU NOT.
ONLY 1.9% OF ALL THE 30 MILLION
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
EVs.
SHORTLY AFTER THIS MANDATE THAT
WOULD BAN ALL NEW SALES OF
GASOLINE POWERED CARS EFFECTIVE
2035, THEY SAID DON'T PLUG IN
YOUR EV DURING PEAK HOURS.
IMAGINE WHEN THERE ARE
20 MILLION OR 30 MILLION EVs
IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WOULDN'T MATTER IF CALIFORNIA
WENT TO ZERO EMISSIONS.
IT WOULDN'T MATTER IF THE
UNITED STATES WENT TO ZERO
EMISSIONS OR CANADA OR GERMANY.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE ANY EFFECT AT
ALL ON THE PLANET BECAUSE OF THE
CO2 SPILLED OUT BY CHINA AND BY
INDIA.
BUILDING COAL POWER PLANTS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THE WHOLE THING IS ABSURD.
IT'S A SCAM THE LIKES OF WHICH
I'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
>> Sean: MARK MEADOWS,
DONALD TRUMP DID SOMETHING I
THINK ONE OF HIS GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT AS PRESIDENT, HE
GOT US TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
HE LEFT OFFICE.
AMERICA WAS A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
I WOULD LIKE TO RETURN TO THAT
AND EVEN TAKEN A STEP FURTHER
AND BECOME THE SINGLE MOST
ENERGY DOMINANT COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD AND I WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE ALL THE ENERGY NEEDS OF
ALL OF OUR WESTERN EUROPEAN
ALLIES AND I THINK THAT WOULD
MAKE AMERICA RICH AGAIN.
LOWER EVERYBODY'S TAX BASE AND
EVERYBODY WOULD PROSPER AND IT
WOULD CREATE HOW MANY MILLIONS
OF HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS IN
THE ENERGY SECTOR.
>> IT WOULD MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
CONGRESS ISRAEL CERTAIN THAT
THEY NEED TO DO INVESTIGATIONS.
PERHAPS THEY NEED TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION ON HOW WE WENT
FROM ENERGY DOMINANCE TO ENERGY
BEGGARS IN TWO YEARS.
LISTEN.
THIS REMINDS ME OF THE
JIMMY CARTER DAYS.
IF YOU REMEMBER HIS ENERGY
SPEECH.
HE SAID YOU JUST HAVE TO GET
USED TO IT.
WE JUST HAVE TO GO THIS WAY.
IT REALLY IS ABOUT THEM DOUBLING
DOWN ON THE POLICY, DESTROYING
OUR RESOURCES, JACKING UP THE
PRICES, AND THEN SUGGESTING THAT
YOU'RE THE PROBLEM.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN LOOK IN THE
MIRROR.
MAYBE THE QUESTION IS IS, I
WONDER IF THERE'S BEEN A CALL
MADE TO THE FRENCH LAUNDRY
RESTAURANT THAT ALLOWED
GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO NOT WEAR A
MASK TO SAY YOU NEED TO SET IT
UP TO 70 DEGREES ON YOUR
THERMOSTAT.
PERHAPS ALL THESE TRAVEL THAT WE
ARE ALL THINKING,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM GOING TO
CHALLENGE JOE BIDEN.
HE IS LOOKING FOR A STATE WHERE
HE CAN COOL OFF.
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
KELLYANNE, OR FRIEND AT
TRAFALGAR CAME OUT WITH THE
POLL.
56.8% OF RESPONDENTS WATCHED
THAT SPEECH IN PHILLY WITH THE
DEEP DARK RED ERIE BACKGROUND
ALTHOUGH IF YOU WASH ON CNN IT .
THEY CHANGED THE COLOR.
ANYWAY.
56.8% SAID IT WAS A DANGEROUS
ESCALATION IN RHETORIC AND THEY
SAID IT WAS DESIGNED TO INCITE
CONFLICT AMONG AMERICANS.
AS FAR AS THE ECONOMY GOES, A
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS ACCORDING
TO GALLUP.
56% AGAIN NOW SAY PRICE
INCREASES ARE CAUSING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FOR THEIR HOUSEHOLDS.
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS ARE NOW
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND
MORE THAN A THIRD OF WORKING
FAMILIES CANNOT AFFORD SIMPLE
BASIC NEEDS AFTER THEY CUT OUT
EVERYTHING THEY COULD POSSIBLY
CUT OUT.
NOW THE QUESTION IS HOW DID WE
GO FROM A PROSPEROUS ECONOMY TO
THIS MESS IN 19 MONTHS?
>> I THOUGHT CNN'S PINK HUE WAS
A LOVELY GENDER REVEAL.
I JUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND IT.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU IN FOCUS
GROUPS AND IN POLLING, WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IS THEY ARE
SCARED.
FEAR AND FRUSTRATION OUT THERE.
YOU KNOW IT STARTED OUT WITH GAS
AND GROCERIES BUT NOW IT'S THE
RENT, MORTGAGE, CAR PAYMENTS,
TUITION, STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT.
EVERYDAY LIFE IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY UNAFFORDABLE UNDER
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS.
HE'S TAKING AWAY OUR BORDER,
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY, PHYSICAL SECURITY.
HE DIDN'T ERASE ANY OF THAT BY
CASTIGATING AND DENIGRATING HALF
OF THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO ATTACK ISSUES.
HE'S GOING TO ATTACK
INDIVIDUALS.
EVERYONE GRANDMOTHER WAS RIGHT.
BIG MINDS TALK ABOUT BIG ISSUES
IN BIG CHALLENGES.
SMALL MINDS TALK ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE MESS WITH JOE BIDEN IS
DOING.
AND NEVER SEEN SO MANY TRY TO
ENGAGE VOTERS BY ENRAGING THEM,
ALIENATING THEM.
IT'S OKAY TO WORK BECAUSE HIS
NUMBERS ARE STILL UNDERWATER.
PEOPLE STILL DON'T HAVE THE
WARMTH FOR HIM, CM AS INSPIRING
AS A LEADER, PASSIONATE, MET
WITH THE PLAN, HAS THE VISION
AND THE ACUITY TO GET THE JOB
DONE.
HE KNOWS WHEN THE REPUBLICANS
TAKE THE HOUSE AND JIM JORDAN
GETS THE GAVEL, HIS SON HUNTER
BIDEN WILL BE THE FIRST
INVESTIGATED.
I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THE COUNTRY
WILL BE FOR THAT BECAUSE THAT
GUY FLEW AROUND ON GOVERNMENT
TAXPAYER-FUNDED AIRCRAFT SHAKING
DOWN GOVERNMENTS AND PEOPLE AND
OTHER COMPANIES.
HE HAD NO ENERGY EXPERIENCE.
HIS FATHER HAS NO ENERGY.
IT'S A BIG HOT MESS.
>> Sean: THE QUESTION, LARRY,
HOW DOES THIS IMPACT THE
MIDTERMS?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S GOING TO
AFFECT THE MIDTERMS.
TOP TWO ISSUES ARE CRIME AND
INFLATION AND THEN USE OR WHEN
GAS PRICES.
PEOPLE ARE VERY GOOD INQUIRY.
THIS TOP-DOWN STUFF, AT LEAST IN
THE LAST SPEECH, HE DIDN'T REFER
TO AMERICANS SMA FASCISTS THE
WAY HE DID A FEW DAYS EARLIER.
WHAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
FASCISM?
IT ALLOWS YOU TO OWN THE MEANS
OF PRODUCTION BUT TELLS YOU HOW
TO RUN THE PEER DOCUMENT
CALIFORNIA.
THEY SET UP A BOARD THAT WILL
ESTABLISH WITH THE WAGES ARE FOR
FAST FOOD WORKERS.
IMAGINE THAT.
A BOARD TELLING YOU WHAT YOUR
READERS NOT TO BE.
A MINIMUM OF $22 A MONTH.
FASCISM IS WHEN YOU ARE ALLOWED
TO RUN YOUR BUSINESS THE
GOVERNMENT TELLS YOU HOW TO RUN
IT.
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Sean: MARKS, WILL THIS BE A
DRIVING ISSUE?
WILL THESE BE DRIVING ISSUES
DURING THE ELECTION?
DO YOU SEE REPUBLICANS, DO YOU
SEE A WAVE THAT MANY ARE
PREDICTING?
I HAD TO MAKE THOSE PROTECTIONS
MYSELF.
>> I HATE TO MAKE THE
PREDICTIONS FOR WHAT YOU LOOK AT
ARE THE FOLLOWING POLL NUMBERS
THAT JOE BIDEN.
LOOK AT THE RATE THEY ARE NOT
LEARNING FROM THOSE FOLLOWING
POLL NUMBERS.
THEY ARE JUST CONTINUING TO
DOUBLE DOWN, TRICKLE DOWN ON ALL
THEIR FAILED POLICIES.
EVEN WHEN YOU GO TO PENNSYLVANIA
AND YOU TALK TO THE PENNSYLVANIA
VOTERS, THEY KNOW WHAT HONEST
AND TRUE IS.
IT WASN'T COMING FROM THE LIPS
OF OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF.